what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so continuing our discussion on
some of these characters that are coming
out of thor ragnarok
we shift our focus to a character by the
name of grandmaster now grandmaster
first appeared in Marvel Comics with
Avengers issue number 69 in 1969
ironically enough and he was created by
a guy named Roy Thomas now Roy Thomas is
an interesting concept when it comes to
Marvel comics because he's basically a
fan who made it the idea was that Roy
Thomas initially found a success with
about eight issues of storytelling in DC
Comics and then was brought over to
Marvel just because of the fact that he
put in his notice then he was fired on
the spot so it's it's got a weird in
terms of how that was done
but with Roy Thomas his early for Ray
and the marvel really came with like
uncanny x-men I guess really just you
know the x-men offer issues 20 through
43 but his first major huge landmark
title really came in the form of the
Avengers beginning somewhat with issue
number 35 now with this year 35 he
wasn't really the main writer he
actually co-wrote the issue alongside
Stanley but because of the fact that
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby had really
elevated Marvel to being one of the top
two come above publishers alongside DC
Stanley was basically being moved up to
the position of editor-in-chief and what
that meant was that for the most part
his writing duties began to sort of back
off in the sense that he would basically
edit stories he would make sure that
they were falling in line with how
things were supposed to be done and for
the most part his brother Larry Lieber
really took up a lot of the writing
chores that Stan Lee wasn't able to
handle but Roy Thomas himself had picked
up officially with issue number 36 and
had written the entire series for quite
some time and when I say quite some time
I meant that he wrote the title for
almost 10 years maybe a little over ten
years in the sense that he basically
stopped in 1975 with issue number 132
and the King wore part two so I mean it
was pretty interesting in terms of his
whole plethora in his his additions into
it but back when he was initially taking
over the title within the first 30
issues or so the idea of the Grandmaster
being introduced was interesting insofar
as he was just a character that was
designed to sort of experiment and
that's one of the things to keep in mind
when it came to 1960s and 1970s Marvel
comics because they had found so much
success with like Thor and Iron Man and
the return of Captain America and
spider-man and so on it was basically
one of these things of not necessarily
the idea that could do no wrong but in
the sense of created throw in a comic
throw it out there and we'll see how
fans respond to
and so the Grand Master made his debut
in a three-part story between issues 69
and 71 and this was all rooted and
really a conflict between the
superheroes involving came to conquer
and the Grand Master himself on the way
to this unfolded was pretty
straightforward it was this idea that
came the Conqueror had love interest and
the offer was made to him by the Grand
Master that if he were to win a conflict
against the Grand Master himself that
Kings love interest would be resurrected
but if King lost then the entirety of
Earth would be doomed and his love
interest wouldn't come back so right off
the bat Roy Thomas basically established
the idea that the Grand Master was a guy
who loved to play dangerous games and
that's a really important concept
because the Grand Master would be the
template for characters that would
appear later on like arcade who was
created by eras Claremont this much
smaller version of Kane the Conqueror
who had things like murder world where
he would set up these really dangerous
elaborate traps but because Marvel was
experimenting with new teams and
concepts and ideas and so on and so
forth Roy Thomas actually played a
pretty dangerous game and the reason why
I say that is for the most part back in
the 1960s and 70s there was a sort of
truce with Marvel and DC in the sense
that you don't make fun of us we don't
make fun of you and we basically just
sort of stay in our own worlds but in
this particular story what Roy Thomas
did is he basically crafted something
called the squadron sinister which was
basically this alternate reality version
in Marvel Comics of the Justice League
and it came in the form of the
introductions of Hyperion Nighthawk dr.
spectrum and the Whizzer of course a
Hyperion being the closest adaptation to
Superman that Marvel has going but on
the avengers side or at least on the
came to conquer side you had Captain
America Goliath
Thor and then a character named Black
Knight who had largely been this outlier
in Marvel Comics for years and nobody
ever really knew what to do with him now
of course this story ultimately
culminated in the defeat of the
Grandmaster and me OK in the Conqueror
winning who chose to use his power to
attack the Avengers and basically lost
the ability to resurrect his love
interest in the process but it was
interesting because along the way to
this story Roy Thomas had introduced a
litany of different things in Marvel
Comics grabbing a bunch of different
characters creating new characters so we
saw things like the introduction of
Ultron we saw the introduction of
characters like vision a creation of
Ultron who was originally a villain
turned Avenger we saw a lot of these
things being rolled in and so because
the success of Roy
is going on to you know see the
co-creation of characters like Wolverine
and Carol Danvers Valkyrie and so on and
so forth what this meant was that he had
basically shot up in the success of
Marvel Comics and so because of that a
lot of people immediately started taking
notice of him now one of the more
notable titles or more notable stories
that Roy Thomas had launched was
something called the kree-skrull war
which was basically in Avengers centric
storyline but it actually ran between
issues 89 through 97 running all the way
up to march of 1972 but again these huge
contributions meant by the time Stan Lee
had basically vacated his position as
editor-in-chief that Roy Thomas
succeeded him as editor-in-chief him so
Roy Thomas backed off from his chores as
a writer and largely just became the
head editor for Marvel ensuring
continuity and different things along
those lines but for the character of the
Grandmaster his next major appearance
came with giant-sized defenders volume 1
issue number 3 has was written by Steve
Gerber which actually served as a
prelude to something called the corvax
saga which is one of these interesting
you know events that took place in
Marvel Comics
but the corvax saga dealt with this idea
named michael korvac who came from an
alternate reality but in this alternate
reality the entire solar system as we
know it had been conquered by a race
called the badoon which are kind of like
these technologically advanced warring
alien race that makes great weapons but
the idea was that core vac was really
kind of a traitor to the human race
working for the badoon and then
ultimately was drafted and you know into
becoming a cyborg don't number the exact
circumstances around it but it basically
led to the Grandmaster showing up yet
again and Marvel Comics and then
grabbing core vac and dragging him to
the main Marvel Universe where he
basically faced off against Co Doctor
Strange and the defenders now following
this and leading into the core vac saga
proper a core vac had basically
discovered the ship of Galactus and the
result was that he essentially just
found a way to absorb part of Galactus
energies and in turn became like this
all-powerful being and so what ended up
happening is he actually ended up going
to war against the guardians of the
galaxy 3,000 I think it was and Thor who
had ended up in the future was defeated
by them and then jump back to the main
Marvel Universe and the reason why this
matters is because what it did is it
allowed Marvell to take the guardians of
the galaxy 3,000 title which was
relatively popular at the time and cross
it over with the Avengers and so it
basically became and Avengers guardians
of the galaxy 3,000 crossover story
which saw them battling against Michael
Kovak
who was just this insanely powerful
person but the Grand Master was just
kind of popping up and just sort of
showed up in this small little tidbit of
storytelling and then for the most part
that was really about it for him however
between June and August of 1982 with Roy
Thomas having left the position of
editor-in-chief and being replaced by a
Jim shooter what Marvel did is they
actually launched their first major
crossover event which is to say a
crossover between a multitude of
different characters and this was a
story called the contest of Champions
now the contest of Champions was this
sort of aftermath or fallout to the
events of the quarterback Saudi in the
sense that during the core backstory the
collector tan alert Yvonne was killed
and this began to add on to what worked
hummus had established with the elders
of the universe in the sense if the
Grandmaster has no true origin story we
don't really know where he comes from
all we know is that he alongside several
other people who were out there that
champion the collector and so on are
what are known as the elders of the
universe in the sense that when the
universe first came into existence they
were among some of the first races to
gain sentience and for whatever reason
their entire race was totally
obliterated and so in response to this
they have in a massive amount of power
and they are very capable but they're
not truly immortal what contest of
Champions did is make them truly
immortal especially what happened here
is that the Grandmaster engaged in this
sort of game of battle with a cosmic
entity death but the idea is that in
this conflict it was essentially a wager
if Grandmaster won and the collector
would be resurrected if he lost then
that wouldn't happen basically
Grandmaster himself for sacrifice his
own life and so what Marvel did is they
grabbed some of the most notable
characters at the time in the sense that
grandmasters team consisted of like
Captain America and Dark Star Wolverine
a daredevil and she-hulk
but then it also had deaths team which
consisted of like vanguard and Iron Fist
sandstorm Black Panthers Sun fire just
some of these characters who Marvel
wanted to raise the profiles of because
they were popular but not the absolute
top tier and so what this did is it
lasted for about three issues and it
resulted in the Grandmaster winning but
what the Grandmaster had to do was
effectively sacrificed his life in order
to bring the collector back and so
following this as part of a to issue
crossover between Avengers westcoast
number two and Avengers annual number 16
the Grandmaster made his return and it
was basically this idea that the
and master was going to take the powers
of mistress death so what he ended up
doing was hitting the main Avengers team
and the Avengers West Coast team against
the Legion of the unliving and then in
turn keeping mistress death away from
the entire equation by effectively
keeping her bonded and so the result is
that she effectively made her escape due
to the fact that Hawkeye had tricked
Grandmaster this ultimately led to
mistress death banning the elders of the
universe from her round and their
entirety and so much like what she did
to Thanos what this did is it
effectively made them immortal and this
says they could never truly die because
mistress death would never accept them
into her realm and so what this did
following that is it led into the Silver
Surfer vol 3 line of stories largely
written by Steve Englehart and this
basically depicted the idea of the
elders of the universe trying once again
to basically take over all things in
existence and that was a recurring part
of their whole storytelling in the sense
that because nobody ever really knew
what to do with them they would just be
interjected into stories where they were
just tried to seize control of
everything but a lot of this came out of
Jim starlings writing back in the mid
1970s the introduction of the Infinity
stones the Cosmic Cube stories and it
basically centered on the notion of them
trying to kill Galactus and then when
the entire universe came to an end
surviving due to the fact that they
could never truly die and then being
reborn into the next universe in the
same capacity that Galan was reborn as
Galactus so it would basically make them
immortal now this lasted anywhere
between Silver Surfer volume 3 issue
number 9 and running up to 19 I think it
was it ran for about 10 issues but again
that was largely that while they played
it was just characters who were backups
for the most part and he would just go
through and implement these schemes to
try to conquer everything in addition to
this with the Infinity stones having
already been introduced in Avengers vol
1 annual number 7 I think it was it
basically led to the Infinity stones
being taken by the elders of the
universe in the sense that it gave
writer jim Starlin the ability to put
them on the back burner but what these
did is they led into the early 1990s
really around 1990 1991 with a story
called Thanos quest and Thanos quest
dealt with the idea of Thanos trying to
capture the Infinity stones now we'll
talk about that more as we get into the
actual Thanos quest story but the long
and short of it is that following one of
his deaths and while he was in the realm
of mistress death herself he had gained
access to something called the Infinity
well and the
well is basically this source of
knowledge that if you ask it the right
question it'll give you an answer to
whatever it is that you're looking for
and he had basically learned that if all
the Infinity stones were brought
together and then put onto a singular
gauntlet or glove he would give it swear
absolute power over the universe itself
and so the result is that Thanos began
traveling to all these different cosmic
entities the in-betweener the elders of
the universe and seizing the Infinity
stones that they had in their possession
and the case of Grand Master because he
was very much a master of games
Thanos had challenged him to a battle of
wits of sorts while the Grand Master
didn't know is if Thanos had actually
sent a cyborg version of himself in his
stead and so the Grandmaster was
effectively locked inside of his own
game while Thanos walked away with the
mind stone and that was really about it
now following this and going into really
the 2000s the Grandmaster didn't really
have much of an appearance when it came
to Marvel Comics I mean he was there but
his defenses didn't really amount to
much in the background
Marvel was going through a lot of
changes Marvel was going through a lot
of things that had to do with a comic
bus the idea that they almost went
bankrupt Joe Quesada stepped in in 2000
basically began seeing if the characters
are not essential if they're not high
sellers don't publish them in too many
stories well that data irritate a lot of
fans who were you know who really
enjoyed characters like Grand Master
because of what they brought to the
table in the end his presence wasn't
really missed by a lot of people in 2009
we had appearances in hope vol 2 by Jeph
Loeb with issues 10 through 12 that was
really about it there wasn't a whole lot
going on with the Grand Master's
character he was largely considered to
be this sort of archaic concept that
peach when it came to meth a nose quest
story and then that was really about it
going into the collapse of the way of
the multiverse in 2015 year 2014-2015 in
the aftermath of that we basically got a
revamped version of contest of Champions
a story that was initially interesting
but it did see the reintroduction of
characters like the century Robert
Reynolds who hadn't been seen for quite
some time and it essentially dealt with
the idea of the maestro Hulk this
version of the Hulk from the future who
would survive this sort of nuclear
holocaust along with a handful of humans
it was the idea
the Grandmaster and maestro began
grabbing these characters from all
throughout space and time basically
these characters who had survived the
collapse of the multiverse and just pit
them in a battle against one another but
ultimately contests of champions was
canceled due to the fact that
it just didn't really sell that well and
it was taught into a game that didn't
seem to perform that well that was
really about it I mean the Grandmaster
hasn't really been seen or heard from
since I mean he's just kind of vanished
and that's really all there is to it I
mean most likely we'll see him making
his return following the events of thor
ragnarok of course he's played by Jeff
Goldblum and that brings us into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe when it comes
to the character of Grandmaster in the
MCU especially when it comes to the
events of a43 he is effectively a
replacement for the Red King and the
reason why I say that is because thor
ragnarok looks to be a combination of
the Planet Hulk storyline and the events
of rocky rock itself in the sense that
for those of you guys who are not
familiar with the Planet Hulk idea it
was basically this notion that Marvel
was prepping for the events of civil war
and what they wanted to do is remove the
Incredible Hulk because he liked Thor
would have turned the tide of battle on
whatever side he happened to be on and
so because of that with the Incredible
Hulk out of the scene
he was basically ejected from the planet
Earth on the auspices that the
Incredible Hulk persona was too
unpredictable to control he ended up
landing on this war-torn planet called
Sekar and the car was being ruled by a
red king who would basically keep the
people happy through gladiatorial games
now this ultimately led to the
Incredible Hulk overthrowing the Red
King establishing a kingdom for himself
but in Thor 3 it looks like the
Grandmaster is replacing the Red King in
the sense that it fits in perfectly the
Grand Master's a character who loves to
basically force people into fighting one
another for his own entertainment
ultimately they'll probably end up
casting off the Grandmaster defeating
him who really knows and ultimately
they'll leave the overall idea here is
that as he'll exists in Ragnarok that
will basically be his depiction in
Marvel Comics a guy who loves to pit
people against each other
because he just loves to see folks fight
and he loves to see who will win that's
just the nature of his character a
master of games you know different
things along those lines now the other
half of this is the power that he
actually possesses essentially Grand
Master possesses what's called a power
primordial now what this means is that
his energy just left over from the Big
Bang the power primordial is just sort
of this power source that Marvel uses to
explain why it is the Grand Master has
like you know superhuman strength and
speed and stamina and durability and so
on and so forth again his character is
pretty powerful in terms of what he's
capable of but much like the collector
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe I don't
really believe we'll see him actually
you much in the realm of conflict we'll
probably see him for the first you know
30 45 minutes if that
and then we probably won't see him again
so that's really gonna be the confines
of him in terms of how he exists but
hopefully this video serves a purpose of
educating you guys in the Grand Master
hopefully you go forward having a better
understanding of his character but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come this explain and make sure you
guys have the sub button to become part
of the Rob cork if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]